[Music]
hey everybody welcome to the amber
ruffin show
the only late-night show sponsored by
milk
milk it makes your fart
we're filming in studio a g in
rockefeller center where seth meyers
films his show
late night with seth meyers we don't
have a studio audience but we do have
a derrick davis he's my announcer
sidekick and real life friend
say hi derek hi tarik fun fact about
tarik he once
killed a man with his bare hands that's
not correct
he once hugged a man with his bare hands
that's correct
you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
during a speech about the coronavirus
this week president biden
said quote the light at the end of the
tunnel is actually growing brighter and
brighter
said americans don't go towards it
[Laughter]
the fda announced plans to ban flavored
cigars in order to help reduce quote
youth initiation which is too bad
because
frankly there's nothing cuter than this
gangster baby
[Laughter]
your mama dies your father died
i want him dead and i get all the milk i
okay but it'll make you fall
according to reports two amateur
paleontologists in florida
found a 50-pound mammoth bone while
scuba diving it's the first
known case of people in florida wearing
masks
according to a recent article several
young white house staffers were put on
probation or fired
after disclosing past marijuana use in a
background check
which brings me to a potentially
uncomfortable question that's
been on my mind for some time
tarek have you ever used
marijuana
[Music]
no interesting
very interesting in fact it's led me to
a potentially uncomfortable question
that's been on my mind for some time
amber have you ever used
marijuana
[Music]
yes damn it ruffin you know the drill
you son of a [ __ ]
you're tough but fair now get the hell
back to the monologue
marvel revealed the title this week of
the sequel
to the 2018 film black panther
it's black panther back in the habit
[Laughter]
you thought we were going to say black
panther 2 electric boogaloo
we did not although i would be totally
down four
new fight scene breakdancing oh come on
how many times did you try to do that
thing with the um broom
oh yeah like home when he was like
trying to let it go
electric boogaloo wow it's a good movie
a luxury bottle of french wine that
spent a year
aboard the international space station
will go up for auction later this year
and will be housed in a custom star trek
themed
trunk with a corkscrew made out of a
meteorite
it's the perfect gift for the man who
has everything
but sex next year's grammy awards will
include two new categories
they are best global musical performance
and
award that should go to a black woman
but won't
and finally lemonade day was this week
which means
fudge making day is right around the
corner
milk oh lemonade around the corner
fudges made the fudge comes out sure but
the fudge is poop
no that was the monologue
tarik did you like the monologue yes can
i hear it again
no you cannot because we have more
things to talk about
okay the scripps national spelling bee
recently unveiled a new format
they're adding multiple choice questions
and even a lightning round to crank up
the competition
but you know what tarek i always felt
like
that spelling bee was unfair they make
you spell words that people never
actually use in normal conversation like
eudemonic
why don't they have words that everyone
uses like
nem ooh i could spell that one
tarik your word is nem
nem can you use it in a sentence
i don't like how you be hanging out with
marcus in them
very good tarik that is correct
all right up next amber your word is
finna finna can i have the definition
um the definition is fixing to
finna f-i-n-n-a
finna amber
that is correct tarik
your word is yamin
[Music]
yami can i have the place of origin
black people
yeah i mean
y a h m
e e n yeah i mean
that is correct amber the word
is i know
can you use it in a sentence
i hate my supervisors so much yeah you
know
yeah i know u o e
n o y no
that is correct tarek
your final word is pandemic
pandemic
p a n
i n i
pandemic that is correct
you win the spelling bee of the panini
thank you i feel absolutely eunemonic
i'm glad to hear it
in other news according to a recent
article health officials are reporting
that a growing number of americans are
contracting covid
despite being fully vaccinated and
no no thank you i don't want anything to
do with this yeah
i don't want to talk about that or think
about that
at all you see
some news gives me the blues
[Music]
some news makes me feel pissed
but some news is just so bad
baby i pretend it doesn't exist
still getting covered after the vaccine
no thank you
that just doesn't exist
some news makes me feel joy
some news fills me with this
but some news is just so bad baby
i pretend it doesn't exist like this
republican senator tim scott said
recently that
america is not a racist country and
president biden
and vice president harris agreed with
him
now i'm gonna pretend like that news
story doesn't exist
is that healthy no tarik nothing i do is
healthy
[Music]
some news i take to heart
some news i just dismissed
but some news is just so bad
baby i pretend it doesn't exist
like this trump was reportedly presented
with a 24-page
proposal to launch his own multi-billion
dollar media company
yeah i i don't think so cause like what
that would mean for people i
that just doesn't exist it doesn't exist
no baby it doesn't exist no
no no baby it doesn't exist
[Music]
that news doesn't exist i have my own
youtube channel now
yay be sure to subscribe for a lot of
show clips and a lot of digital
exclusives
and a lot of this
[Music]
you